well hope you all had a good weekend
everything everything went went okay for
me save my Baltimore Ravens losing
yesterday though though I did enjoy I
did enjoy one thing that happened during
the game I went went to a bar with my
wife to watch it because we got three
kids so if I want to watch a game this
is what this is the point we're at now
if I want to watch a football game I got
to hire a babysitter leave the house go
to a bar
not that I'm complaining my life is so
hard I had to watch a football game at a
bar that's how difficult my life is
anyway we were there and and at one
point the Ravens marched marched down
the field they scored a touchdown not
not enough to win the game but this fan
at another table after the touchdown he
turns to someone else at the table and
he goes see what I tell you they need to
take the ball go down the field and
score a touchdown and that was those
that's one of the things I enjoy about
about watching football is that it gives
you a chance to make insightful
observations like that and everyone does
it and I do the same thing actually at a
different point during the game the
Ravens were trailing and so I turned to
my wife and I said we really got to put
some points on the board here and it was
just it was a you know because it was
just something was it was a moment of
inspiration that came to me I realized
you know what we could use points that's
the thing and oftentimes the best part
is when you give advice to the players
while they're playing so a lot of times
like if a player drops you know wide
receiver drops the ball doesn't make the
catch I'll say something I'll say oh
come on you got to catch that it was in
your hands and the great thing is
because they can hear that of course and
it is also good advice because then they
hear that they say oh that's Oh catch it
you mean that's what I'm supposed to do
so that's um that's that's that's part
of watching football but I hope that
that you're if you're a football fan
that it went better for you and if
you're not a football fan then get the
hell out of the country you communist
speaking of Communists there were a
bunch of climate protestors swarming DC
this morning shutting down the morning
commute trying to shut down DC as as
they put it which in a nut
context I'm perfectly fine with shutting
down DC I'm all about that but not the
way they went about it but it leaves a
question of what were they trying to
accomplish exactly and whatever they
were trying to accomplish is this a
reasonable way to go about it we're
gonna we're gonna try to tackle that
today but first a word from vistaprint
you know I can't tell you how many times
I've been out and this is true I you
know I go out someone comes up to me we
get to talking and then they say okay
can I have your card and I don't have
one and so I have to do the embarrassing
thing where's I yet I don't really have
a business card it's extremely important
to have business cards if you want to
look professional if you want to take
advantage of opportunities when they
come you got to have that card you got
to have it ready to whip out and I've
learned that the hard way and that's why
I now use Vistaprint your next big
opportunity is coming right now and
they're here to help you own the now
with free shipping on any business card
in any quantity choose whatever style
finish shape or paper you like it's free
shipping and because you could pick the
colors fonts designs and images it means
you can create something as unique and
compelling as your business ready to get
started on business card it's easy just
number one you plug your information
logo into hundreds of fresh designs
tailored for your type of company number
two you pick the paper stock style
quantity that's right for you and then
the third step you can you can upgrade
to a unique touch like rounded corners
whatever you want to do and then you
order and receive your cards with free
economy ship it's as easy as that
Vista Prince wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity just go to vistaprint.com enter
promo code Walsh for free shipping on
all business cards any style any
quantity limited time offer own the now
at Vistaprint com promo code Walsh you
support our show remember when you
support our sponsors okay so we talked
last week about the climate strikes and
climate walk outs at school well that
that's still going on today
of hippies decided to shut down a bunch
of intersections in DC as a means to
save the environment I guess but of
course forcing a bunch of cars to idle
on in the road probably isn't gonna do
much to help the environment stopping
global warming by causing traffic jams
that's that's certainly a
counterintuitive way to do it but I
think I'm not sure how much it's really
going to to accomplish the group's
Facebook page says they're going to
quote block key infrastructures to stop
business as usual bringing the whole
city to a gridlock standstill parents
workers college students and everyone
who's concerned about the climate crisis
will skip work at school and put off
their other responsibilities to take
action on the climate crisis this is the
mass uprising that everyone with
climbing anxiety has been waiting for
this is an uprising for life itself
fighting back against the forces of
destruction this is your chance to take
action to save the people plants and
animals you love let's rise to the
challenge and shut down DC mass uprising
let's take a look at this mass uprising
here are some sights and sounds as
documented by spectrum News look at this
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go there is the the mass
uprising they're going to save the
planet and that's how they're doing it
they're dancing in the street and here's
a group called extinction rebellion
which sounds like the lamest name for a
90s punk band you've ever heard but
they're not making music they are
instead strapping themselves to a boat
in the middle of the street again this
is to save the climate save the
environment remember and and here's what
that looked like after the natural
treasure that we're losing every single
day and also because
[Music]
[Music]
so there you go there and police had to
come and spend a lot of time getting
those people unstuck from the boat
because they weren't gonna tow the boat
off of the the road without first
cutting the the chains to get them out
now I think you could make an argument
look if you're gonna disable a vehicle
or a tow a boat out into the middle of
the highway and then chain yourself to
it I think police would be well within
the rights to just tow the thing off the
road with you attached to it because
that was your choice right but they
weren't gonna do that in fact the police
were extremely understanding and polite
and cooperative the entire time and this
seems to be a theme with left-wing
protests and we call it protest this is
the we can't this isn't really a protest
this is just this is illegal is what it
is to to walk into the street and shut
down shop you can't do that that's not
legal you're not allowed to just do that
if I went into the middle of street if I
went out outside right now and just sat
down in the middle of the street okay
the police would probably come and drag
me off the street if not arrest me but
the thing with these left-wing
quote-unquote protests is that it seems
like they're given a ton of leeway to
just do what they want and nobody gets
arrested
Julio Rosa us on Twitter gives us a view
of just to give you an idea of the
traffic and the the the gridlock that
was caused by this he gives us a view of
one of the traffic jams caused by these
people take a look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
now if you if you've ever been to DC
which I don't recommend going but if you
have ever been especially during rush
hour especially on a Monday of all days
you know that it's hell on earth as it
is it is absolutely miserable I have no
idea why anyone would choose to live in
a place like DC but that's another
discussion entirely but you take that
imagine how it goes when it's already
that bad without any idiots in the
street blocking traffic on purpose
imagine how it would be when you do have
the idiots in the street blocking
traffic on purpose
it's obvious of course that most of
these protesters don't have jobs they
were just protesting last week and they
and and the kids were skipping school
last week so now they're skipping school
again but not all these people are
school-age as you could tell some of
them would look like they are working
AIDS yet they're not working and that's
how they're able to protest four days a
week but now they're trying to stop
other people who do have jobs from
getting to their jobs and making money
to feed their families and let's
remember that it's not like DC is made
up only of lobbyists and bureaucrats
that is an unfortunate percentage of DC
but there are also working-class people
who work you know in the restaurants and
in the places where those lobbyists and
bureaucrats go for for lunch or whatever
else these protesters are stopping those
folks those working-class folks from
getting to their jobs also and that's
the thing about left-wing protests is
that they so often betray a total
contempt for the working-class because
they have no compunction about shutting
down traffic about preventing people
from getting to their jobs they don't
care about that because they don't have
jobs themselves because they've got
mommy and daddy taking care of them and
or they've got daddy government taking
care of them and so there as far as
they're concerned the rest of you could
just screw off they don't care not their
problem I really hope I eat all those
people who are stuck in traffic
I hope they took note of who these
people aren't whose side they're on or
more precisely who's on their side
because people on their side are not on
the side of the working class that's for
sure so let's review in order to save
the environment they're causing traffic
jams there they're causing local
forcement to waste resources they're
impeding people's abilities to get to
their jobs that's the plan here that's
the strategy oh and they're littering
also on purpose watch this yes yes
that'll do it
great job there that'll save the planet
I mean that guy is literally prancing
down the street throwing trash on the
ground he's skipping down the road just
throwing trash on the ground and this
isn't in a protest in favor of the
environment and that's what he's doing
you might as well just take an aerosol
can and spray it in the air say in the
environment yes you might as well just
do that it's the same exact thing oh and
they're lighting trash on fire too look
at this picture that somebody took an
actual dumpster fire that was lit by
these people who care so much about the
environment so as with every other
left-wing protest much of this is just
an excuse for unemployed morons to dance
around in the street and feel important
that's what most of this is they're
begging for attention attention not for
the cause but for themselves they want
attention for themselves that's what a
lot of this is and that's why protesting
is so popular these days I don't think
it's a coincidence that we've got all
these protests that that it seems like
now that everybody's got phones and
everyone's on social media and so
everyone's also carrying a pocket or a
camera around in their pocket it seems
like now that that's the case we've got
protests four times a week and why is
that because these people they want you
know they want the opportunity for the
selfie they know they're gonna be on
Twitter on social media and that's what
they want it's for them it's got nothing
to do with the cause
what it really comes down to and I'm not
trying to be cynical about it you know
you know me I would never be cynical I'm
that's the last thing I am no one would
ever accuse me of that but it seems to
me if you really cared about the
environment
you wouldn't be blocking traffic you
wouldn't be stopping people from getting
their jobs
you wouldn't be littering you wouldn't
be dancing in the street all of which
has nothing to do with helping the
environment and is only going to
undermine your case both by the by the
damage it does to the environment and
also by the fact that you're just taking
everybody off and you're and you're
making them less sympathetic to your
cause
who is gonna see that if you're if
you're in traffic because of these
people are you going to be more or less
likely to be sympathetic to their cause
if you didn't care that much about the
environment when you got in your car to
go to work that morning are you gonna
care more about it now because you've
got a bunch of environmentalists in the
street stopping you from getting there
is is there any chance of a strategy
like this doing anything positive for
the cause that it's ostensibly supposed
to supposed to help no of course not
which leads me to the cynical conclusion
that this isn't really about did all
these protests whether it's this or a
t-4 whatever it's not about whatever
thing they have on the on the banners
and all the poster boards it's just
about them if you're really cared about
the environment I think what you would
be doing instead you would take a more
serious and sober approach and you would
be leading by example now whenever
someone makes this point and I made this
point before and I'm always accused of
doing a kind of cheap lame
gotcha thing that if you really cared
about the environment and what are you
doing on your phone wouldn't you be but
but there's truth to that it's not a
gotcha if you're telling me look if you
really believe
that the world is actually coming to an
end potentially and soon in the next few
years you really believe that and you
really believe that what we're doing the
way that we're living is bringing about
a doomsday then wouldn't you be making
radical changes in your own life and and
and and thereby number one making sure
that you yourself are not contributing
to the problem and number two leading by
example if you think that radical
changes need to be made in the way
people live which which it which is
supposedly your message then why aren't
you making those radical changes
yourself and showing us how to do it and
and showing us that it can be done why
aren't you doing that and these
environmentalists they're not because
you can see them they're just like
anybody else yeah they go to the protest
and then they go home to their normal
house with their phone and all this they
got the refrigerator they got everything
they got their car they're not making
any changes in the way they live it's
not a gotcha moment like like with with
the aoc when she says that we got we
gotta get rid of airplanes and air
travel because of what it's doing to the
environment and then she gets on an
airplane and she flies and and we say
well what are you doing flying you just
and then and then the response I was
I'll come on don't don't don't do that
you're being don't tell me you're being
pedantic it's not pedantic if you're
saying that we this is a sacrifice we
need to make then make the sacrifice to
show us yeah it it's it's it would be
very difficult to have a job that
requires travel and not use an airplane
that is difficult but you're the one
telling us that well those are difficult
things we need to do so do it and show
us
so aoc could actually say you know I'm
not gonna board a plane as difficult as
that is as hard as it's gonna make my
life doing what I do whatever that
happens to be I'm not gonna do it in and
I'll show people that it is possible
yeah it's harder but it's possible it's
just
very striking that very few of these
environmentalists are doing that yeah
you know what I mean I think I've
mentioned before I have one of my you
know there are people very close to me
who I I know in my family who live you
know out on homesteads and and solar
energy okay
all of that stuff compost toilet all
right I people here close to me that
live the way not not because they're
environmentalist hippies but just
because that's how they want to live but
so I know it's possible to live that way
why aren't more environmentalists living
that way it's it's politics it's a
sacrifice for sure it's a it's a it's a
very different way to live it's possible
to do this a lot to be said for it
actually even if you're not an
environmentalist I think there's a lot
to be said for it i gets definitely see
the appeal so why aren't they doing it a
for goodness sakes I'm Dutch well we had
what twelve years until the end of the
world or at least until until until a
catastrophic that will potentially be
the end of human civilization at a
minimum and I just don't get it yeah I
think these people that are out in the
street they really should they should be
out living in the woods in a cabin
compost toilets solar energy you know
nuts and living on nuts and berries like
John the Baptist locusts locusts and
wild honey maybe you hunt for game I
don't know but I'm not sure if that's
okay or not because of the
environmentalist thing but whatever I I
think that that's how they should be
living show us show us how to do it and
how wonderful it is and how possible it
is to live that way until you're gonna
do that I reserve the right to just
completely ignore you because I think
you're fraud and if you don't take your
own
seriously then why should I take them
sir this is the same thing that I say
about Christians I've had this message
many times you know we as Christians we
have to take our own religious claims
and like I said last week
environmentalism really is a religion if
you don't take your own invite religious
claims seriously and try to live by them
then why should anyone pay attention to
what you have to say if you don't even
take it seriously then why should they
alright let's a couple of things before
we get to emails this one quickly Megan
Fox remember her she was in what was she
in she was in some stuff she was in she
was in some movies I think anyway she
appeared on a talk show a couple days
ago and and there's no better way to
regain some relevance in America than to
go on a talk show and brag about your
cross-dressing child that's the way to
do it you want to get attention you want
to speaking of getting attention you
want to be relevant and that's what you
do and she did and she's being
celebrated for this by the media people
on social media here's what she had to
say about her cross-dressing
six-year-old boy listen to this he's
really into fashion and he's the one
like sometimes he'll dress himself and
he likes to wear dresses sometimes and
he'll and I send him to a really liberal
like hippy school but even even there
here in California he still has little
boys going like boys don't wear dresses
or boys don't wear pink and so we're
going through that now where I'm trying
to teach him to be confident no matter
what I don't know
he finally he had stopped wearing
dresses for a while he just wore one two
days ago to school and he came home and
I was like how was it did any of the
friends at school have anything to say
and he was like well all the boys
laughed when I came in but he's like but
I don't care I love dresses okay a
couple of brief things here the other
boys at her son's school are correct
they are correct that boys don't wear
dresses so she says that like it's a bad
thing she says I I send my kid to a
hippie liberal school but even even
those boys say uh boys don't wear that
yeah they're right
that's except that s'right there they
are correct their reaction of looking
sideways at that of of maybe even
laughing at it that's the right reaction
because you know why because it's absurd
it is absurd for a six-year-old boy to
be wearing a dress and going to school
that is an absurdity it's an absurd
thing and as human beings when we see
absurdities we react to it we reacted
away usually that that is consistent
with the fact that the thing we're
looking at is absurd now it's it's it's
very sad and unfortunate that her
six-year-old boy is dealing with that
and has to endure that treatment I don't
like that I think it's a terrible thing
I think it's I I think it's very very
sad but whose fault is it here's the
point whose fault is that is it the
fault of the other six-year-old boys is
it really their fault when they see some
kid coming into wearing a dress like
it's really their fault that they're
that they're looking at that like what's
he doing we're gonna blame them
and not you as the mother for putting
your six-year-old boy in a dress who's
to blame here and don't about I didn't
put him in that he chose it
shut up you put him in that your
six-year-old boy does not have any
clothing that you didn't buy for him he
doesn't wear anything that you don't let
him wear so don't tell me how he made
his own choice and and if it's just such
a coincidence isn't it that you have all
these radical liberal parents who just
so happened
to have kids and sons who just so
happened to want to express their gender
identity but cross-dressing no you
didn't encourage that at all no not at
all they just so happened to want that
bull okay that's bull your six-year-old
boy wants to wear a dress 99% chance is
because you pushed him in that direction
because you want that because it makes
you feel enlightened and everything and
even if it'll ostracize as your kid or
makes him feel uncomfortable but it puts
him in line for bullying you don't care
because this is all about you your child
is just like some accessory some some
some fashion statement I really hate
this I hate what people do to their kids
I hate it when they treat their kids
this way if your six-year-old boy he and
you know what else I I I'm willing to
bet Megan Fox and her these Hollywood
parents I'm willing to bet if their kids
wanted to go to school in Kmart clothing
what if they wanted that what if they
wanted to go back go to school in Kmart
clothing what if they wanted to go to
school in clothing it was dirty and had
holes in it I bet you then you'd have a
problem you say no no you don't wear
that to school because that's gonna make
you look poor and cheap and you don't
want that so if your kid's gonna wear a
dress it's going to be a nice dress
isn't it's gonna be a really nice one
it's gonna be expensive brand-name I
just let my
expressives no you don't you let your
kid express express himself in ways that
are reflective of your ideology that's
what you're doing and you know it what
if your kid wanted to go to school
everyday and miss matching shoes what
about that you know what if you wanted
to wear a Nike on one foot an adidas on
the other I bet you wouldn't let him and
you shouldn't actually is it gonna hurt
him is it morally wrong to wear
mismatching shoes if you want to take a
really reductive view of it good that it
is is it a big deal at all no but it's
absurd okay so unless you are poor or
something and that's all you have and
that's all you could put your kid in in
that case you do what you you got to do
to survive to get by but if you have an
option you're gonna put your kid in
matching shoes even if he wants to wear
mismatching shoes at six years old now
if he's two years old he wants to run
around the house and miss it miss
matching shoes he's out it's cute you
laugh about it but it's six years old
he's old enough now you wear matching
shoes why just cuz that's what people do
that we are we you're teaching your
child how to be a functioning person in
a civilized society and so you tell them
no you wear this is this is how you wear
your shoes okay you want to wear the
shoes on the wrong feet cuz that's how
you express yourself no you but you want
to but you're not going to okay because
because kids want to do a lot of things
that are just that we shouldn't let them
do isn't that the crazy thing I got
three kids I got a fourth on the way I
find myself saying no to my children
constantly and having nothing to do with
with them wanting to gender bend because
fortunately that hasn't but that hasn't
been an issue again coincidentally you
know I don't have any great desire for
my kids to gender bend and so weirdly
coincidentally strangely they themselves
have never expressed any real desire for
that again it's just that it's at odd
coincidence where you have these really
super liberal enlightened parents who
just so happen to have kids who just so
happened to one
that weird isn't it that's not
conditioning at all is it
but any case uh in so many other
contexts I am telling my kids no you
can't do that you can't do that stop
doing that stop clay stop climbing that
stop trying to eat that stop wearing
that snot you know this is what you do
as parents because we have to because
kids don't know anything about anything
they have no idea how to function as as
as humans in society so you teach them
and that's gonna require a lot of no
it's gonna require a lot of control
especially in the beginning and then as
they get older you give them more and
more freedom and if they get to be 18
years old and they want to wear
mismatching shoes they can if they want
to wear a boot on their head and go to
and go out that you know they can you
would you would ret you would recommend
they don't but they can in the beginning
though as parents we we are there to to
give them instructions and but even if
you even if you see know even if you
personally see no real problem with a
kid cross-dressing and doing the gender
Bend routine even if you personally see
no real issue with it and you should
because there are issues with it but but
even if you don't I mean how about just
protect your kid how about just don't
don't put them in line for that kind of
bullying I get I know it makes you feel
good it makes you feel good to have kids
that are bullied for that because it
makes you feel like a really enlightened
and courageous parent so great good for
you pat on the back here's a cookie you
want a lollipop you can have one too
okay but but it's not good for your kid
your kid is not a social experiment so
so why not give him a chance to just
have a normal childhood and be a normal
kid a normal boy make friends you know
how about just give him that chance and
if he gets to be 18 he wants to go wear
a dress out but he can do that but by
then it's gonna really be his choice not
yours I really hate this this stuff
we're doing with our kids I just I hate
it so much it is so unfair to these kids
all right finally ABC News has a video
of what they're calling husband of the
year husband of the year's wife was in
labor for two days so he went to the
delivery room with his camera rolling of
course and well let me now now I so I
want to show you this I want to get I'm
interested to get your opinion I that's
the honest truth I especially as a woman
if you're a woman watching this I would
like to get your if it or a man because
men can have babies too I'm told so so
if you're a man with a baby or a woman
bit by the way I mean I'm interested to
get your opinion on this what you think
of it and I'll give you my I'm not
looking to you know make fun of this guy
but he's the one who put this online for
everyone to see so you put it online so
let's take a look at it this is what he
did for his for his his wife who was in
labor watch this
[Music]
okay what do you think about that
ladies if you're in labor if you're
listening on iTunes or SoundCloud you
couldn't see that what happened was this
woman she was in labor for two days and
her husband came into the delivery room
with with these big flash like flash
cards and on the flash cards he had
little messages that he wrote little
loving messages and he had it on camera
near the camera rolling and he he showed
her one at a time the messages on the
flash card which had a bunch of nice
stuff about how I don't know I love you
and you'll be a great mother and blah
blah blah and and and so but here's my
question why what why I feel like if my
if my my wife is gonna be in labor any
day now any day now we're coming up
against it and when she's in labor I
feel like if I went in with a whole
stack of flash cards and said hey honey
just I want to show you something if you
could just stop you could just calm down
for a second I want to show you this
look look at these flash cards and I
just started going through the flash
cards what she would be sitting there
with this look on her face like and then
she would either laugh in my face or
kick me in the stomach maybe both I
think maybe a kick in the stuff as a
swift kick in the stomach and then laugh
in my face maybe the other way around
I don't know but I think that would be
her reaction if you want to go and be
supportive of your wife while she's
giving birth that's a great idea why not
just say it whatever you wanted to say
on the flash code just say it in use
your words like I say to my kids all the
time use your words and say it there's
an idea I don't know
but my main thing is why do you need to
have it on film that's what I don't get
why do you got to put on it it's it's
your wife's giving birth to the delivery
room there is no reason to ever in my
opinion have a have a have a video
camera rolling in the delivery room I
just you don't need to even
especially not if you want to put it
online but even if for your own
recollections I I don't the the
experience of someone giving birth is
it's it's that's a very it's gonna be
very vivid in your mind you you won't
need to go back and see the camera
footage to remember you'll remember it
so I can't imagine if I had video of my
wife and the liver I can't imagine
sitting there years later well you
remember this let's watch the video
again but even if you want to do that
that's your business just don't put it
online you want to do something nice for
your wife whether it whether it plays or
not whether it works out you don't it
doesn't need to be videotaped does it
videotape I don't know why I still say
videotape you don't need a videotape it
so you could put it in your VCR kids
these days all right um
that was very sweet that was very nice
one Matt well show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from Michael says hi
Matt thank you for your honest and
accurate assessment of why young people
are leaving the church for the Southern
Baptist Convention the figure is 80%
plus from 2005 of young people that
leave the church at 18 years old and
never return
oh is staggering it's a staggering
number as a newcomer to the Christian
Church myself I experienced exactly the
problems you spoke about ie
evasion easy but incorrect answers etc I
had to come to Christ partially on my
own and also through the good example of
my landlord who invited me to the Alpha
class program because I was desperate
for ant I don't know what the Alpha
class program is but because I was
desperate for answers and heard only bad
things and tales of hypocrisy from so
far so called Christians now that I have
found Christ I understand it is still a
constant battle to maintain my beliefs
in faith for example
am I really a Protestant or is
Catholicism the correct faith and that
is a minor point compared to doubts that
crop up from time to time from about
things I read in the new and old
testaments the bottom line is as you say
that we need a mature and modern
understanding of these documents one
that puts them in proper historical
cultural archaeological and theological
perspectives but that doesn't shy away
from the disagreements within branches
of Christianity while also uniting
believers
Christ which is what the Alpha program
tries to do also understanding that what
Christ asks us to do and what we want to
do are often not the same things if we
didn't have to battle with sin we would
be God but since we do what is honest to
admit that we fall short of the glory of
God anyways long story short just wanted
to thank you for your honest and
accurate talk from today's September
21st version of the show thank you at
God speed and thank you for that Michael
I there's nothing I really need to add
to that but but I thank you for
listening and for that input and insight
as well especially as someone who just
recently entered the church and
congratulations on that by the way this
is from Jeffrey says dear Matt as a
church-going high schooler who's deeply
involved in my youth group and church I
could not agree with you more on your
perspective on youth ministry I've read
my Bible consistently for the past 400
days and I get the impression that I do
it more than the vast majority of mature
adult Christians you certainly do if
you've been reading consistently for 400
days that's more than most adult
Christians I've ever spent reading the
Bible I also feel like that in order to
get the deep hard-hitting theology and
apologetics that I crave I'm forced to
seek it out independently whether that
be looking for the internet sitting in
on an adult small groups that
occasionally meet at my house or reading
the books by intelligent theologians
like Sproule lewisham or Piper one of
those names does not belong with the
others that's all I'll say three of
those people are brilliant theologians
nobody ever discussing things like the
apparent contradictions of the hard and
difficult passages at my youth group re
or in chapel sessions at my school which
has filled me with a deep resentment for
both activities I also get the feeling
that my pastor is oblivious to this
because he never avoids hard questions
or difficult passages and so he's really
the only person in my life I have
interest in listening to as a youth
myself it is blatantly obvious to me why
my peers are falling away the people
that are supposed to be educating and
training us are only trying to make
Jesus look appealing and not preaching
anything that will be of serious use
when we move away and go to college
where our faith will be harshly
challenged and the allure of sin will be
strong I think that all young Christians
should realize that their faith has to
be taken extremely seriously and I also
believe that the adult church that is
supposed to be an example to us is
seriously lacking
and thank you for that again Jeffrey but
okay these so they weren't I didn't only
get emails of agreement but I believe
believe you me on that one this is one
from someone who's not quite in
agreement says four miles Matt I thought
your analysis of why people leave the
faith was way off and very troubling if
anyone leaves it means they were never
in it to begin with if you lose your
faith you never had it it's not possible
to lose faith if it's real the fact that
you don't realize this makes me question
your faith frankly well miles thanks for
that really appreciate it you're totally
wrong unfortunately what's more I think
your position is arrogant and put
pretentious and a sign of intellectual
cowardice and I really don't mean any
offense by that you want to think that
anyone who leaves must have been a fraud
all along because that gives you an
excuse to not take them seriously to not
listen to them and especially not to
listen to any of the questions they
might have about faith not to listen to
any of the reasons they might give for
why they left it gives you license to
ignore their objections completely and
to continue living in your bubble and I
find that frankly pathetic and I don't
mind saying that because you know you
you clearly wanted to make this a
personal thing I don't mean it as a
personal think that's just how I see
that and in your your bite by no means
alone in this in this idea that anyone
who it's not PI if you real if you
really have faith it's it's not possible
ever to lose it
I just to me that's ridiculous
to me that is self-evidently ridiculous
you're suggesting that it's impossible
to believe something and then not
believe it anymore you're denying a
basic fact of human nature it's just it
is definitely possible for someone to
believe something and then not believe
it they really believed it and now they
don't that that's a that's a thing
people do that now and and they could be
wrong you know someone could believe
something and be right and then believe
something that's wrong that
that happens or they could be wrong and
then believe something of it it's that
those these things happened that's how
the human mind works we're not you know
it you just just because you come to a
conclusion and say oh I think this that
doesn't mean you're gonna stick with
that conclusion forever you could change
your mind for better or worse that does
happen and to deny that it happens it's
just why well I know why I'll get to
that in a minute but you certainly have
there's no rational basis to deny that
we all you know in your own experience
miles that there had I would hope there
there have been things that you believed
you're putting religion aside maybe not
religiously but you there have been
things that you believed and then later
came to the conclusion that you were
wrong or have you never done that have
you never in your life ever change your
mind about anything if so then I would
say that that you're that's a sign of
being a very closed-minded person but
probably you have and so you know how
that works you really believe something
and now you don't okay it does happen
but I think the bigger problem is is is
you are accusing every single person who
has ever left the faith of either being
liars or too stupid to understand their
own reasons and their own mind so when
they say yeah you know I really believe
this and now I don't anymore because and
they give a reason like you know
whatever I rattled off a bunch of the
objections and questions people have who
leave the faith I did that in the last
show you can listen to it but okay just
just for one exists someone says I left
the faith I really believe in God but I
didn't because for example I was reading
the Old Testament and it just seemed to
me that the god of the Old Testament is
a moral monster and I just can't believe
that anyone would would endorse this guy
okay that's that's a that's a very
common objection that you hear from
people who leave the faith very in my
experience a very common they'll cite
the Old Testament and the things in
their slavery genocide rape you know all
these things
not all of it certainly endorsed or
commanded by God but that's but that's
the that's the impression that some
people that
any people have when they read it
actually and that's the reason they get
now rather than you engaging with that
reason and saying you know listen I
think you I think I think you have a
misunderstanding of the Old Testament
text let me talk about rather than doing
that what you're saying is oh then you
never believed at all you were a fraud
you're lying now that's not really why
you left or you're too stupid to
understand why you left yeah you never
really believed in the first place
that's what you're saying to them maybe
not in those words but that's the
message that's the message they hear no
it is indeed possible for a person to
believe in God with all their heart and
then too at a later date come to the
conclusion that they were wrong in my
opinion it is a that's a wrong conclude
the new conclusion is wrong they were
right before but that happens people do
that you know they were right and now
they're wrong you just have no basis at
all none none to claim that they never
believed what they say they believed
before that's how you want to look at it
you see Myles that's why I called
intellectual cowardice is that you want
to see it that way you hope that it's
that way that's how you would prefer to
see it because you don't want to take
them seriously and you don't want to
engage their objections maybe you don't
know how to maybe you haven't studied
this stuff yourself the objections that
people raise for example about the Old
Testament those are serious objections
they're not crazy
the fact is read the Old Testament read
it there is some really troubling stuff
in there that you can't deny denying
that is not gonna help and so to in so
suit to to confront those objections
head-on it is it can be a difficult
thing intellectually emotionally and so
it seems to me that you would prefer to
avoid that and so instead you like at
you never believe I don't know if the -
whatever this is exactly the kind of
attitude that makes the problem worse
you know you're making it worse you
personally are making yours if someone
has a crisis of faith
if they leave the faith and you're
sitting there completely D legitimizing
their experience completely discounting
their reasons for leaving and
away their previous however many years I
mean someone let's say someone was was a
Christian for 40 years and then they had
a crisis of faith all this stuff they
leave that you're sitting that you're
just waving away 40 years of their life
thank that now was nothing didn't mean
anything
wasn't real they are it was perfectly
reasonable for them to respond and say
how dare you who the hell do you think
you are how could you possibly know what
was in my mind before where do you get
off making those kinds of declarations
this is just not the right approach I
cannot stress this enough I feel so
strongly about this as you could tell so
I'm talking about it again I just it's
really really bad this is not the right
way to go about it you are chasing
people away you might as well go to a
church with a broom and just swat people
away to get out get out of here you
might as well do that it's the same kind
of thing it's just so so wrong I think
the right approach is to go to them and
say listen your doubts are valid even
reasonable your questions are good
questions the things that you're
bringing up about this or that Old
Testament problem of suffering you know
going down the list those things I've
thought about them too this is what you
could say I thought about them too
it's something that I've had I have
wrestled with it also if you've never
wrestled with it then you just then you
have no business even you know you
certainly have no business passing any
judgment on them if you've never even
wrestled with these questions but if
you've if you have wrestled with them
and that's all the more reason to go up
to them and say look I get I get it I
understand why you're wrestling it is
this is tough stuff but let's talk about
it let me give you some ideas about how
we might sort through this let me give
you some some people you might read
who've done a good job who helped me
when I was going through the same thing
you did I think that's the right
response saying oh you were never a
Christian to begin with you're a fraud
that is a remarkably stupid way to
respond to a person
crisis of faith and all you are doing is
all but ensuring that they will never
come back because this is the other
thing I hear I told you yesterday I hear
from all these people who have had had
these crises crises and talking about
the questions that they had and so on
the other thing I hear very often is
that when they were in the midst of this
crisis or or even when they came out on
the other end of it and they found that
they had no faith anymore the the
response from the church and from other
Christians was so horrendously bad and
that that they just said you know what I
don't want nothing to do these people
these people are this is I'm like I
don't want it I wouldn't want to I'm
done goodbye this is a real problem I
mean it is a real problem in the church
[Music]
and I'm sure I've been guilty of it to
myself but we really need to take a step
back because 80% and the number you had
this is the second email I've got now
people claiming eighty ninety percent
from what I've read I have read those
studies say eighty nine and it depends
on what the nomination what church but
some churches some denominations are
losing 80 and 90 percent of the next
generation some a good figure would be
like losing 60 percent or something this
is this is catastrophic it cannot go on
do I understand if it continues like
this there will not be Christianity in
America in another 50 years it won't
exist in this country that's where we're
headed so I think it's a good idea to
step back and to do a serious
reexamination of everything I mean just
all the ways that we usually have
approached this problem our entire way
of thinking about this problem of people
leaving the faith why they leave how we
should deal with it we need to
re-examine all of that because it's
clear that we are doing something wildly
wrong and I think miles you gave us an
example helpfully of one of the very
wrong ways
that we go about this alright I guess
we'll leave it there thanks everybody
for watching thanks for listening if
you're in DC today I feel sorry for you
I'll pray for you God have mercy on your
soul and Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is
produced by Robert Sterling associate
producer alexia Garcia Del Rio executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
his Austin Stevens edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin hosted
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]